hi I'm max I'll install and today I'm
gonna walk with you creating your own
private certificate authority with
Google clouds new certificate authority
service this new service can help you
simplify the deployment management and
security of private CAS without managing
infrastructure let's take a look from
the console go to security
then certificate authority service if
you haven't yet enable the API now
create a new CA choose root CA and
choose a region you can also see below
that we have some pre-made recommended
configurations to help you save time
with CA creation next configure the new
CA filling out the necessary fields the
ID is the unique identifier for this
resource inside Google Cloud and will be
used by other services now we need a key
in this case I've already created one
using the key management service which I
add at this step you can do the same way
or use a hardware security module key as
we update the certificate authority
service we'll be adding the ability to
create a key from inside this tool now
onto revocation for when we need to tell
clients to no longer trust this
certificate we use certificate
revocation lists to communicate this you
can turn off CRLs with this box below
you can also decide to enable authority
certificate publication that enables
chain validation code on a recipient
device to navigate the full certificate
chain to the root next you can add a
label to enable easy grouping of your
cloud resources one final review to
finalize details before you create if it
all looks good then let's run with it
you'll now see the newly-created
certificate authority under the CA
manager tab great we've got our
certificate authority set up let's
request a certificate for my fictional
get snacks to joggers on-the-go company
eat and run choose the authority you
want to use and click request
certificate click on provide CSR then
add your certificate signing request in
the text box I'll use one I made with
open SSL you can see all certificates
issued by your CA under issued
certificates click on the dots to
download any certificate for inspection
or use congratulations you've created a
new CA and gotten a new certificate in
minutes much faster than the days or
weeks it would take to host it yourself
check out the link for more details
about certificate authority
[Music]